[Applaus]
[Musik]
migration ist dieser tage überall ein
heißes thema hast du dich aber jemals
gefragt welches land den größten anteil
an migranten im verhältnis zu seiner
gesamtbevölkerung hat was würde mit
einem land passieren dessen bevölkerung
zu sagen wir 85 prozent aus migranten
besteht wenn du jetzt denkt ich sei eine
rein hypothetische frage dann solltest
du jetzt mal gut zu hören bekommen in
den vereinigten arabischen emiraten
kurzhaar in einem land in dem nur etwas
mehr als zwölf prozent seiner einwohner
tatsächlich emirates sind ja so ist es
tatsächlich zur zeit sind sieben von
acht menschen in den vg eingewandert und
die vg sind nicht das einzige land mit
solch einer krassen einwanderer quote in
katar sind nur 15 prozent der menschen
staatsbürger konkret bedeutet dies dass
in städten wie doha der hauptstadt
katars mehr ende als aber leben und ob
ihr es glaubt oder nicht diese zustände
sind für die länder am arabischen golf
überhaupt nicht ungewöhnlich tatsächlich
ist die bevölkerung jedes landes dieser
region mit ausnahme von oman und saudi
arabien mehrheitlich ausländische je
nach land liegt der anteil der
ausländischen bevölkerung zwischen 30
prozent im fall des otto arabiens und 88
prozent wie eben in den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten
diese länder haben den höchsten
ausländeranteil an der bevölkerung in
der welt zum vergleich in den usa einem
land in dem einwanderung eine lange
geschichte hat und immer noch ein heiß
diskutiertes thema ist beträgt der
anteil der ausländer an der bevölkerung
weniger als 15 prozent
wie aber kam es zu dieser situation am
golf sind die arabischen länder einfach
eine bastion des liberalismus und der
toleranz und öffnen ihre türen für jeden
ausländer dort leben und arbeiten möchte
ist es vielleicht so dass sich diese
from länder moralisch verpflichtet
fühlen flüchtlinge aus den zahllosen
kriegsgeplagten ländern der welt
aufzunehmen nein ganz und gar nicht da
waren grund warum diese länder so viel
ausdauer aufgenommen haben ist dass ihre
wirtschaft komplett von ihnen abhängig
ist wie abhängig nun fast der gesamte
private sektor einschließlich der
ölindustrie besteht aus ausländischen
arbeitnehmern und nein übertreiben nicht
zb waren anfang 2020 nur fünf prozent
der beschäftigten im privaten sektor
kuwaitische staatsangehörige während
ausländer 85 prozent der arbeitskräfte
aus machten im jahr 2018 waren in den
vhs einem land mit über einer million
bürgern weniger als 40
eigene staatsbürger in der
privatwirtschaft beschäftigt eine
weitere folge dieser situation ist das
der größte teil des inländischen konsums
dieser länder von ausländern getätigt
wie du weißt du thot wir hier auf visual
politik immer wieder die
wirtschaftlichen vorteile geregelte
einwanderung aber wenn die gesamte
wirtschaft an bekannten abhängt dann
kann dies in bestimmten situationen zu
einem ernsthaften problem werden
und genau diese situation ist im jahr
2020 mit der korona krise eingetreten
das experts dubai verlassen ist eine
schlechte nachricht für die wirtschaft
bloomberg juni 2020 die migranten am
golf kommen und gehen und dies stellt
eine ernste bedrohung für die gesamte
produktions- dienstleistungs- und konsum
und infrastruktur da letztendlich
besteht das risiko dass diese
gesellschaften in einem sich selbst
verstärkenden abwärtsdruck geraten und
vollkommen zusammenbrechen und da man
sich am golf dieses gigantischen
problems durchaus bewusst ist geht es
die dortigen politiker auf sagen wir mal
ihre eigene weise an
viele dieser länder versuchen eine
politik zu fahren die sie para visierung
nennen
in kuwait nennen sie es die sierung
catania sie erst arisierung und so
weiter was aber bedeutet dies ist damit
gemeint hast all die systemrelevanten
ausländer jetzt eingebürgert und mit der
einheimischen bevölkerung auf eine stufe
gestellt werden also gar nicht diese
ganzen easy rungen bedeuten nämlich dass
diese länder ihre wirtschaft auf ihre
eigenen nationalen bio ureinwohner
stützen und die eigenen bürger irgendwie
doch noch in den privaten sektor
einbinden wollen denn sie wollen sich
nicht länger auf leute verlassen müssen
sie einfach wieder auswandern
und irgendwie haben sie auch gemerkt das
ist ganz gut wäre wenn die eigenen
bürger irgendeine nützliche
qualifikation aufweisen können sobald
der ganzen ölreichtum versiegt wie aber
sind diese gesellschaft überhaupt zu dem
geworden was sie heute sind wird es
ihnen gelingen ihre arbeitsmärkte zu
avisieren
heute werden wir alle diese fragen
beantworten aber vorher werden wir wie
immer einen kurzen blick in die
geschichte
kann das nicht jemand anders machen
viele dieser länder stehen was er
ähnlichen problemen und haben eine sehr
ähnliche wirtschaftsgeschichte sehen was
also mal katar als beispiel an
katar war einst eine bitterarme esel
aber anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
und in den 1980 er jahren wurden erhöhen
und vor allem gas entdeckt so wolle das
land innerhalb weniger jahrzehnte vom
armen schlucker zum land mit dem
höchsten pro kopf bruttoinlandsprodukt
der welt auf dem weg dorthin gab es aber
einen gewaltigen haken im jahr 1980
lebten nur 200.000 menschen auf der
insel
und diese waren keine bergbauingenieur
das extrem arme land verfügt auch nicht
über universitäten welche diese experten
für die gasindustrie hätte auf die
schnelle ausbilden können ich möchte dir
vorstellen kannst von welchen
mittelalterlichen verhältnissen wir
sprechen auch noch heute gibt es in
katar gesetze wegen hexerei
das problem dürfte also klar sein für
die förderung von gas braucht man tag
und eine menge intelligenter gut
ausgebildete und hochgradig
spezialisierte fachleute keine
hexenjäger extrem spezialisierte
fachleute wenn man bedenkt dass katar
dieses gas verflüssigen musste damit ist
in schiffen um die ganze welt
transportiert werden konnte
die technologie um sogenanntes liquid
natural gas lng zu erzeugen erfordert
nun mal hochgradig qualifizierte
arbeiter ohne sie gibt es keine
möglichkeit aus den natürlichen
ressourcen profit zu schlagen also wie
qatar nichts anderes übrig als
ausländische arbeitskräfte anzuheuern
und zwar als gäbe es kein morgen bis
1980 waren die ölfirmen größtenteils in
staatlicher hand
aber sie ließen oft westler dinge wie
management und technik erledigen danach
begannen sie ist südasiatische
entwicklungsländer die indien und
bangladesch für die knochenjobs
anzuheuern und durch sie die
einheimischen araber zu ersetzen so sehr
dass sich die bevölkerung bis zum jahr
2000 in nur 20 jahren also fast
verdreifacht hatte größtenteils durch
migration sowie jetzt mal wie groß die
bevölkerung katz im jahr 2020 war ein 23
millionen einwohner ihr fängst du
vielleicht aber markt stehe diese länder
nicht im ruf extrem strenge islamische
gesellschaften zu sein
wie kann es sein dass die so viele
ausländer aufnehmen von denen fast alle
entweder christen hindus oder buddhisten
sind die kunden sie sich damit abfinden
dass zwei drittel ihrer bevölkerung
nicht muslimisch sind wir stellen vor
die doppelmoral es stellt sich heraus
dass es bestimmte strenge islamische
regeln zu inländer gibt das
für ausländer ja das ist richtig können
zum beispiel ein amerikanischer
gastarbeiter in katar wir kaufen will
kann er das ohne probleme
gut ist nicht billig sein aber es ist
möglich das liegt daran dass die meisten
gesetze die alkohol verbieten müsse in
länder gelten aber ausländer davon
ausgenommen sind sogar christliche
kirchen sind in diesen ländern erlaubt
passt franziskus selbst war im jahr 2019
zu besuch in abu dhabi sondern immer
nicht versucht als missionar muslime zu
konvertieren
darf man so was sagen glauben problemlos
praktizieren tatsächlich gibt es in
diesen ländern viele einrichtungen
zwischen bars nur für ausländer in denen
die islamischen gesetze einfach nicht
gelten
westliche experten ihren lebensstil in
netten wohngegenden beibehalten die
fitnessstudios clubs und sogar
internationale schulen und fassen sie
trennen die expats buchstäblich vom rest
der bevölkerung zumindest soweit dies
überhaupt möglich ist wenn die expert
bevölkerung ja schon den mehrheit aus
macht all das mag ich nicht gut klingen
von wegen integrationsverweigerer und so
aber wenn man darüber nachdenkt ist ist
die art und weise wie diese
gesellschaften ist geschafft haben ihre
traditionen zu bewahren und gleichzeitig
nicht nur mit ihrem ex es zu
koexistieren sondern in unglaublichen
maße von ihnen zu profitieren
im großen und ganzen haben die dinge
also irgendwie funktioniert aber braucht
eingebildete wrestler und billige
asiatische arbeitskraft und die westler
und asiaten waren glücklich sich für
einen anteil am süßen ölgeld zu
verpflichten und sie mussten sich noch
nicht einmal an die verrückten gesetze
dort halten
klingt doch eigentlich vernünftig oder
nun auf den ersten blick ja wenn die
ganze sache nicht doch wieder einen
gewaltigen haken hätte viele dieser
länder haben etwas was man kavala system
at ok worum handelt es sich bei diesen
tafalla system nun das wichtigste was
wir jetzt hier zu merken muss ist das
ist etwas unglaublich schrecklich es ist
es handelt sich um eine hinterhältig
raffiniertes system moderner sklaverei
mit hilfe dieses systems werden arbeiter
ins land gelockt indem ihnen eine
vielfaches ihres einkommens daheim
versprochen wird um aber erstmal ins
gelobte land zukommt müssen sie einen
einheimischen sponsor vorweisen dieser
sponsor in der regel der arbeitgeber ist
für den rechtlichen status des migranten
verantwortlich und dabei entfaltet sich
eine dynamik die sehr leicht zu massiven
missbrauch führen kann
im besten fall bedeutet es dass man
keinen anderen job annehmen kann als den
den der sponsor einen gibt dieser kann
einen auch die derzeit feuern und aus
dem land werfen lassen denn es im
schlimmsten fall ist man
im grunde läuft der lohnt wird einfach
einbehalten der passt konfisziert und
dann ist man einer vielzahl
unvorstellbarer misshandlungen
ausgesetzt denn es gibt niemanden da
niemanden der einem hilft schon bald
diesen relativ milden ist aus holland
cotter wenig fortschritt beim schutz von
wanderarbeitern seit august 2009 10
warte ich auf geld sagte ein 34 jähriger
ingenieur der wegen sieben monaten nicht
gezahlter löhne vor das arbeitsgericht
zug und sich geld von freunden in katar
borgt human rights watch 2020 und das
was in katar geschieht passiert auch in
den meisten anderen golfstaaten
natürlich hast du dich jetzt wieso
angesicht dieses schrecklichen
kaffeebars systems überhaupt noch
migranten in ingolstadt bekommen nun so
schrecklich es klingt für viele ist dies
die einzige hoffnung auf ein bisschen
wohlstand viele dieser gastarbeiter
kommen aus sehr armen gegenden und
erhalten am golf löhne die weit über dem
liegen was sie in ihren heimatländern
erwarten könnten
und wenn die dinge tatsächlich nach plan
laufen könnte sich vom geld das sie am
golf angespart haben eine schöne
immobilie in der heimat kaufen außerdem
planen mehrere dieser länder
nach wachsenden internationalen druck
das kv system zu reformieren der
letztlich stellt ist nicht nur ein
problem für die ausländer dar sondern
wird auch für die regierung in der
gesamten region zu einer immer größeren
bürde
willst du wissen warum sorgen sich diese
regierung ist plötzlich so sehr um ihre
billigen arbeitskräfte oder sorgt sie
eher dass ihre gesamte wirtschaft von
ausländern betrieben wird schauen wir
uns das doch mal genauer an
ausverkauf der produktionsmittel
[Musik]
wenn wir nur den privaten sektor dieser
länder betrachten könnten wir glauben
dass die deutsche bevölkerung so gut wie
gar nicht mehr existiert als hätte sie
sich seit den 70er jahren einfach in
luft aufgelöst
oder man würde einfach denken dass
keiner der einheimischen arbeit hat aber
das sind nur die daten des privaten
sektors in wirklichkeit in den meisten
einheimischen schon irgendwo beschäftigt
nämlich als beamter das heißt wenn man
in den fond eine privatbank betritt kann
man davon ausgehen dass fast alle
angestellten ausländer sind aber sobald
man ein staatliches ost antritt sind
überall nur noch einheimische das macht
gerade bei diesem beispiel auf den
ersten blick etwas seltsam klingen das
ist eine so krasse trennung zwischen
inländern und ausländern öffentlichen
und privaten sektor aber glaubt mir das
ganze ist doch viel nerviger aus wenn
man es etwas genauer unter die lupe
nimmt
denn was wir dann entdecken ist nichts
anderes als ein system welches wir gut
und gerne als sozialismus mit arabischem
antlitz bezeichnen können was wir damit
sagen wollen nun die einnahmen dieser
länder stammen fast alle aus der öl- und
rohstoffförderung diese länder verteilen
dieses geld dann an ihre einheimische
bevölkerung nein nicht durch ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen sondern
durch wohl schon jobs beim start erlaubt
die regierungen dieser länder schaffen
im grunde nur arbeitsplätze damit sie
einen vorwand haben ihren staatsbürgern
geld auszuschütten
natürlich machen auch diese beamte nur
ihren job aber unter ganz anderen diesen
bequemen bedingungen als alle anderen
sie müssen keinen strengen arbeitsplan
einhalten und effizienz kontrollen sind
für sie ein fremdwort
dann gibt es aber noch andere vorteile
wie zum beispiel extra urlaub wirklich
fette gehälter und boni wird nichts tun
in manchen fällen kommt ein beamter in
katar ein grundgehalt von mehr als 9000
dollar um und klingt doch ganz nett oder
und ausländer an die ganze drecksarbeit
machen und gibt den eigenen bürgern
langweilige schreibtisch jobs was könnte
da schief gehen nun eigentlich eine
ganze menge
das erste und offensichtlichste problem
hier ist das alles auf einen stetigen
fluss des gastro ölreichtums aufgebaut
ist das bedeutet wenn öl und gas nicht
mehr so viel geld einbringen so wie es
jetzt der fall ist sagen wir dinge an
ungemütlich zu werden
genau an dieser tour ihr steckt momentan
saudi arabien aber viele andere länder
wie kuwait und bahrain stehen vor ganz
ähnlichen problemen und wenn sie dieses
problem nicht lösen werden sie
irgendwann anfangen müssen die
unproduktiven busche arbeit
abzubauen saudi arabien ein land mit
einer sehr jungen bevölkerung hat
bereits einen sättigungsgrad erreicht an
dem es einfach nicht mehr möglich war
mehr einheimische im öffentlichen sektor
einzustellen und genau aus diesem grund
schoss dort plötzlich die quote der
arbeitslosen jugendlichen aus
katastrophale 27 prozent hoch und war
dort bis heute
zum vergleich die jugendarbeitslosigkeit
in deutschland liegt bei fünf bis
sechstausend welche pläne haben die
araber um dieses problem zu lösen und
wird irgendwas davon überhaupt
funktionieren nun lasst uns darauf mal
einen blick werfen
[Musik]
einheimische einstellen also wie klappt
es mit der politik der fatah regierung
saudi sierung und so weiter wie ich
bereits erwähnt habe
die golfstaaten wir nun sich ja sehr
stark private unternehmen zu motivieren
einheimische einzustellen und das klappt
mehr oder weniger seht ihr mal folgende
meldungen 101 prozentige anstieg der in
der privatwirtschaft eingestellten
emirates in diesem jahr
realisierung ein schleichender erfolg im
privatsektor
so muss aber gesagt werden dass trotz
all dieser gut klingende nachrichten
dieser zahlen einfach nur
lippenbekenntnisse sind was die frage
aufwirft was da eigentlich abläuft nun
es gibt einige gemeinsame ansätze so gut
wie alle länder haben versucht
technische studiengänge zu fördern
einheimischen mit unternehmen so
vermessen und natürlich das beste
allheilmittel gegen inkompetenz
überhaupt quoten ist dieser
gemeinsamkeiten das heute jedes land
aber auch voneinander unterschiedliche
ansätze ihr pulver experimentierten sie
zum beispiel in einem subventionssystem
hören bei dem ein unternehmen staatliche
zuschüsse erhält wenn es einheimische
mitarbeiter einstellen da die meisten
dieser länder sehr niedrige oder gar
keine steuern erheben gibt es kaum
steuervorteile die sie gewähren könnten
in kuwait gibt also von der regierung
einen ordentlichen zuschuss für jeden
kroatische staatsbürger denn eine
private firma einstellt ja in diese rate
mal wie das ergebnis aussagt ist
wahrscheinlich erraten tolle zahlen auf
dem papier aber keine echten
arbeitsplätze werden viele unternehmen
schufen einfach song die arbeitsplätze
und hatten leute auf dem lohnzettel die
dort nicht wirklich arbeitet so welche
die firmen aber ordentlich zu
beziehungen vom staat kassieren
ich entwickelte sich zu einer wahren
solche so dass die regierung das
programm schließlich wieder einstampfen
musste war ein wiederum verfolgt eine
strategie die mehr peitsche als
zuckerbrot darstellte eigentlich handelt
es sich sozusagen und das gegenteil der
strategie kuwait bahrain ließ
tatsächlich gesetze welche regel die
größte anteil bei heimischen
staatsbürger an der belegschaft jedes
privatunternehmens sein muss und jeder
verstoß gegen diese quote wird hart
bestraft
es wurden auch gesetz erlassen die es
aus ländern verbieten bestimmte jobs
anzunehmen während gleichzeitig der
mindestlohn für paradies erhöht wurde
[Applaus]
banken müssen zum beispiel mindestens 50
prozent bereinigt anstellen
modegeschäfte 30 prozent aber baufirmen
kommt mit nur läppischen first rock
center von das ergebnis hier nun formell
hat auch das irgendwie funktioniert
irgendwie könnte dies auch zum weiteren
ausufern der chronischen ineffizienz und
geringer produktivität der bach
heimischen wirtschaft führen wenn das
jedoch ein land gibt das wirklich große
probleme mit der beschäftigung
einheimische arbeitskräfte in der
privatwirtschaft hat dann ist das saudi
arabien denn obwohl 30 prozent der
bevölkerung aus seiner und ländern kommt
tragen diese 30 prozent die gesamte
produktive wirtschaft und dies ist nicht
nur ein wirtschaftliches problem sondern
auch ein kulturelles die vorstellung
dass die arbeit von ausländern erledigt
wird ist so tief in ihrer kultur
verwurzelt dass viele saudis überhaupt
nicht bereit sind zu arbeiten vor allem
natürlich ist um manuelle arbeit oder
dienstleistungsjobs geht und dies wird
noch durch die tatsache verschärft dass
viele von ihnen keinerlei technische
ausbildung haben sicher die meisten
jungen saudis studieren an der
universität aber statt ingenieurwesen
oder zumindest finanzen zu studieren
entschied man sich die meistens für
orchideen fächer wie islamische
theologie islamwissenschaften oder
arabische literatur und natürlich
entspricht eine solche qualifikation
selten den bedürfnissen von unternehmen
von dynamischen innovativen start-ups
die sich im weltweiten wettbewerb gegen
china indien die usa und europa
durchsetzen wir schon ganz zu schweigen
genau solche lieder bräuchte dich
saudische wirtschaft aber am meisten
eigentlich ist ohne sie zu einem
grausamen dahin siechen verdammt und
diese problematik findet sich überall an
gold aber besonders schlimm ist die eben
in saudi arabien ausgeprägt der grund
allen übels ist also dass viele aber
einfach nicht bereits in irgend einen
praktischen beruf auszuüben denn sie
haben ja über viele jahre gelernt warum
sollte man überhaupt selbst schwer
arbeiten wenn wir noch einen migranten
dafür einstellen kann
diese sich über mehrere generationen
festgesetzte mentalität der arroganz und
faulheit haben natürlich dazu geführt
ist die meisten über keinerlei
sozialisation ob aus der familie oder
dem kulturellen umfeld verfügen um sich
die nötigen fähigkeiten und eine nun mal
notwendige arbeitsmoral anzueignen
dies alles ist eben genau so eine frage
der kultur wie eine der politik des
bildungswesens und wirtschaft oder ganz
platt ausgedrückt
wie verdammt nochmal soll man diese
ganzen verwöhnten und wegen und
degenerierten bengel verwöhnter
unfähiger und degenerierte eltern dazu
bringen irgendwas nützliches im leben
zustande zu bringen
dieses problem ist nicht einfach zu
lösen und wenn seine lösung nicht
gelingen sollte wird dies in die
katastrophe führen
schließlich ist es ein wichtiger aspekt
für diese länder ihr wirtschaftsmodell
von einer schwindenden ressourcen weg zu
verlagern und wenn die einheimischen
bürger noch nicht mal die kriterien
erfüllen
von einem normalen privaten unternehmen
eingestellt zu werden
wie kann man erwarten dass die selbst in
der lage sind unternehmen zu gründen und
zu führen das ist nicht irgendein
problem es ist das problem dieser länder
und die uhr tickt unerbittlich was meint
ihr
während sich die arabischen nationen aus
ihrer abhängigkeit von ausländischen
arbeitskräften lösen können wird es
nicht in 20 oder 50 jahren noch um
gesunde volkswirtschaften handel oder
werden sie zu facetime generieren
schreibt uns bitte eure meinung in die
kommentare unter diesem video
denn wie immer sind wir auf diese schon
sehr gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefällt und auch etwas gebracht
hat was ja gibt es mit einem like und
unterstützt uns in dem ihr dieses video
mit euren orden teilt und was sie
unseren kanal noch nicht abonniert dann
holt das wird schnell nach und vergisst
auch nicht das kleine symbol um
rechtzeitig über neue videos
benachrichtigt zu werden macht gut und
bis zum nächsten mal